but as you were saying for for hbo max
though yeah yeah that's something you'd
want to do
yeah you'd be great i just want to be
you know have a fan in there
who is a filmmaker who really
understands the characters and then the
hashtag
aaronshonggy4homex got picked up and
that started you know
popping up all over the place and i
don't know what stuff does i mean the
fans
start that petition online which i don't
know what that does but it's up to like
eleven thousand uh hey it could do you
never did these
days honestly it's happening yeah
you know that ever that competition i
was like oh well they started the the
petition
on like the fourth day it was out which
and by that point we already received
like three million views
so i was like i was i want to yell at
the fan and be like you should have
started this on day one you mastered
aaron can you hear us i can what's going
on oh it's a pleasure to meet you
it's an absolute pleasure to meet you my
god this is so surreal to me
you have such a lovely nerd set up right
here like it's it's kind of
putting ours to shame right now it's
your symmetry and all that stuff
oh thanks yeah my my whole place is
coated with superhero stuff if you
turned around i got tons of action
figures and everything so i love
everything superheroes you know
superheroes and and the beatles
as well well i mean who doesn't love the
beatles right
i am into that and hey but you got you
also have like a
see we're just going to size you up
based on this
you guys know because you also have a
stack of championship like super bowl
games and i'm like
you're like it must be a super nerd but
also have a heavy interest in sports so
like you're a unicorn right here
i love um i know cause some people call
me a nerd and i'd be like i know
i always try to like as a as a kid you
guys are probably my age too
like nerd was always like an insultive
thing and you never wanted to be the
nerd but nowadays it's like
nerd pride yeah and then it's like nerds
are sometimes like
i love everything from harry potter to
lord of the rings you're like well
that's not really
out of a whole bookshelf right yeah so
but uh i'm i'm a big tom brady fan so
he's wanted
a lot yeah sports you know
my great uncle played football and so
it's like a big thing in my family
trying to be real diverse sports music
everything you know superheroes yeah you
wear a lot of hats
literally figuratively yeah
but it's cool though it's good a lot of
it's all my my father's
uh influence you know he's a artist and
football guy and
he loves superheroes you know so oh i'm
curious was your father like he's is he
someone who's always encouraged you to
kind of go down this path or did he ever
have any resistance towards you like
going after these pursuits
super into it i mean like couldn't be
more supportive he's like like a
renaissance artist where he can sculpt
and paint and he's a musician he plays
like four instruments and like like
classically
a musician people call me an artist and
i'll just be like i'm robin to his
batman he's so much more you know
talented and he's like a unicorn too
because he's like a huge football fan
like huge football and
that's where i got that from and so uh
and he was into super heroes like what's
funny is that he was the first person
to cosplay darth vader back in 77 and
dress up and it really it wasn't
cosplaying back then
but i have this photo of him where he
made the star wars costume back in i
guess may of 77
and he took photos of it and i was going
i was like i was like this is a photo of
you with darth vader
and then he had behind him he has like
you know the wings and beatles posters
so it's like clearly authentic and i
posted it
online and starwars.com lucasfilm
reached out to me i'm like what is this
and i was like
that's my daddy dressed up as star
they're like this is the earliest photo
we have of anyone ever dressed
oh how cool wow that's so cool
so they did a whole article on
everything if you go if you google like
uh
first darth vader cosplayer like right
now they do this whole article on him
and they interview him and it was like
totally this unexpected thing
how fascinating oh yeah can we can you
bring your dad in here
talk to your dad now
well actually i mean it seems like such
a family-oriented unit that you had
growing
i noticed we noticed in the in the
credits and not just in
uh batman dying is easy there's someone
with your same last name who's also
credited with you is that your brother
that's my dad
yes that's your dad that is your dad
okay okay
awesome and then you do stories about
batman where there's so much connection
to the fatherhood
yeah of all these rights do you think
there's some kind of correlation there
at all like from a psychological sense
with i mean
i'm real close with my family that's
like my number one part i grew up
with a lot of love i was blessed um real
close to my mom
and my 92 year old grandma who's still
alive she also partly raised me so like
what happened to bruce wayne is like
without a doubt like would have been my
biggest fear
and it's like if the train track gets
switched and that's what happened for
bruce wayne like how much would that
like
just wreck you you know and i often
think about like at the end of the film
or batman talks about i don't want to
have what happened to me happen to
anyone else
and what i think what he means by that
almost is not so much the loss of
his parents like i don't want anyone to
lose their parents because that's
inevitable
because i don't want anyone else to
become batman because my life is so
cursed so it just shows like the loss of
parents created this even bigger
psychological problem that he has that
he can't
get around so i like just the psychology
of what would something that
catastrophic
do to you like they say like the day
that bruce wayne's parents died bruce
wayne died and they say when you have
trauma happen to you when you're like
eight or nine you haven't quite
really formed that bridge in your brain
and it's like he would be it's like it's
almost like bruce wayne is forever like
a really really smart eight-year-old
which is why
he sees everything in black and white
and he doesn't understand things and why
like dick grayson is almost smarter than
him in a like more humanity way when he
tries to explain relationships and bruce
is like i don't understand and you're
like well
and that's why i always thought it's
cool why bruce adopted
dick because it's like you're my equal
even though bruce is like 30 and dick is
like 10 at that time he's like but we're
kind of the same because bruce is still
10 in his mind you know i just like the
psychology of it that's why
i try to show and and dine is easy and a
lot of it cause we don't ever get into
that most films you know like batman's
always
the most boring character in his movies
which is like i think terrible because
he's the most fascinating it's probably
because like the voice like christian
bale
can't you know he's like voice and you
can't have a conversation then ben's got
the modulator
which is cool i mean they're cool in
their own right but we never allow
i want to hear batman talk because he's
so brilliant and that's why he like
narrates in the comics and stuff so just
that whole world
is so fascinating and it's so rich and
going back to what i was saying i think
it's because bruce has so much
love and so much compassion that the
bigger that was like the harder you fall
and like he had you know his parents
were his whole world
and then when he lost that it just
decimated him and like growing up as a
kid like that was always like this big
fear because i could tell all that love
is like that's everything you know you
get that
pulled out and you're like i have
nothing so i think that's like
what happened to bruce and i see myself
as like i
like you know thomas and martha survived
with me and we made it out so i'm gonna
like live the best life i can you know
i live a good life for bruce you know so
i live for bruce wayne
and thus because you avoided that fate
now you played the joker
yeah right it seems like you have such a
great understanding of bruce wayne
especially with his core traumatic
memories and how that really shapes him
like yeah both both john and i are we've
both been in therapy ourselves for like
10 years and so like understanding
psychology
was something that is both kind of
natural for us at the same time
it was very present in this short film
or like both actually
i saw the other one that you did ages
ago city of scars right
that's what it was yeah the city of
scars and then even here it's easy to
kind of chalk it up to
oh he's honoring the film noir side the
frank miller side
of batman that we've seen which you are
but there does seem to have a deeper
kind of like um psychological
understanding of these characters
did you ever yourself want to play
batman as well was that something that
you ever wanted to know
i've never wanted to play batman i i
mean the last time i wore a bad suit i
was probably eight or nine
you know as we all have when we're
younger for like halloween or whatever
but
um i've loved batman as a character
since 89 batman 89 came out my dad was
really into comic books
um you know so i kind of came into it
before even the movie
i like psychology and what's kind of
interesting is i'm not a huge
i'm not like a huge action action fan i
like my films to have a lot more
depth to them otherwise it's just eye
candy and that's great but it's kind of
like
it's i would say like how many snickers
can you eat some of these action movies
nowadays it's just like action action
action you're like i like a snickers but
i couldn't eat 30 snickers bars like it
just would kill me that's a good
metaphor
i think that what's interesting about
batman is is all that
undertone action is really a second tier
thing like i don't know if you guys
i'm a big fan of the show columbo which
is quite a while ago i watched with my
grandma all the time but like there's no
action in that it's just all
him manipulating and him with detective
work and that to me is what batman is
and he can do the action and he's
obviously he's become
so much of that but it's like i want to
see just like psychology what makes him
tick
why would you do this like you're such a
broken character that who pushes through
that he walks that line
of not falling over and that's why in
this film we really talk about like why
he doesn't kill
because in like you know the christian
bell movies he says my one rule but he
never explains why that
is one rule and the ben affleck movies
he does kill which i don't like it i
think it fundamentally like destroys the
character i think that batman is like
he's like i hope joker dies like he's
like
he's like i'm with all of you gotham
citizens you know joker should die he
goes but i can't do it he goes because
i'm holding on to so little of my
humanity that if i
lose that humanity i will become a
villain and i'm more powerful and
smarter and psychotic than everyone in
arkham so he's like i can't do it but
gordon
if you want to shoot joker in the head
be my guest i just
can't do i can't pull the trigger and
it's interesting to see batman that's
why the variant of our film he says it's
a monster that i both
fear and embrace because i feel like
there's like in his head
there's this little eight-year-old bruce
wayne who has like a dog caller around
this monster of batman and he's
constantly like i'm trying to use this
thing for good
which is why bruce is a kid feels cursed
if i let this monster off the chain
i'll never get it back and i will i will
just fall into the recesses of my mind
so
to me that's really what's kind of
fascinating about batman that never
really gets talked about
like how do you justify how psychotic
batman is i mean psychotic that's what's
interesting that's why he can look at
all these villains and go like
i understand you he looks a joker and he
goes i can see part of myself from you
right
and that's why it's almost like he has
not so much empathy or sympathy for
these villains but like all the you know
gotham citizens are like kill joke or
kill freeze and batman's like i
understand these villains more than i
would like to
and that makes me understand them and
makes me scared of myself
you know what i'm saying yeah and it's
like how do i use that
to win the day you know what i'm saying
you don't want to like you don't want to
be like i relate to charles manson i'm
like that's not a good thing
but you're a hero so use that to
you know defeat them and make sure they
don't harm anyone but don't fall over
you know so i mean yeah you have to get
inside the other guy's mind you have to
identify in some way so that way you
i mean that i think the detective side
of what you're talking about is
extremely
present um especially in the scene with
joker because
and i think i actually brought this up
in our reaction for it was how
initially that scene when joker which i
do want to talk specifically about your
performance in a second i was like okay
we've seen this
this kind of philosophical discussion
what really got me was the fliparoo
afterwards of like the reveal of oracle
yeah it was in his ear the whole time
this whole thing he was able to
have enough foresight to see that joker
would do
all of this and he was manipulating the
situation like that to me was one of my
favorite aspects that
i have not seen captured in uh any of
the live-action batman's i gotta say by
this particular point
it's cool because you got um is it kevin
porter
you got him in the role who is this
jacked up dude looked him up on
instagram and i'm like this guy can
bring such gravitas to batman like
you're talking about the pain that
batman has to go through and how he is
really just a little boy
inside of this massive body you know
and i love how uh he brings
such depth to that role when you're
directing him are you working
on all of that are you kind of just
letting him do his own thing
well the good thing with there's a lot
of great things with kevin as uh as
batman
um and i've known kevin for 16 years
he's one of my
closest friends he's family he's a huge
batman fan in itself like he's been a
batman fan his whole life so he really
understands the characters and we'll get
into in debates and conversations about
batman and like the different like the
way they think and why would it be this
way and
um you know kevin's a little older than
i am he started reading comics in the
70s
uh late 70s so he comes in with the neil
adams and denny o'neal
and which is which was a little
different mindset and that's kind of the
interesting thing just even about batman
in general is that
batman changes every like 10 years so
what might be my definition of batman
is not necessarily maybe today's kids i
see people like well batman doesn't do
that or what about joe chill and i was
like well the batman i grew up with he
didn't know who killed his parents so
there was this big open you know whereas
joe shield was introduced in the early
80s and then they wrote them out and
then the chris nolan film brought him
back in
and then they've kind of taken him out
again so it's like there's a lot of
those different things but with kevin um
they say kevin's he's a huge guy he's
6'5 like 240
he's massive and then in the suit yeah
he's so big he's so big and he has this
great voice
well it's funny being on sick because a
lot of people i take a lot of pros with
kevin and then i'll go to conventions
and like
they'll be like aaron you're a lot
taller than i thought you'd be i'm like
i'm six foot
like kevin is like six one or whatever
and i'm like this much shorter i was
like kevin's just a monster i was like
he's just this giant
person it happens all the time people
think that i'm not very big and i was
like
it's just kevin's huge and and which is
uh there's some real tension here i'm
sensitive
yeah it's kind of funny but i love
though because
you know i love michael keaton as batman
he's you know is my favorite but he's so
small and batman to me the way that jim
lee alex ross and neil adams draw and
baman is this
is just this monster he's this you know
mountain of a person and
and it's always cool watching people
come to set or even when they meet kevin
because they have this sort of like
overwhelmed
feeling which is i was like that's what
you would probably have when you would
really see batman
and when you see kevin because then he
has the armor and he has the ears and
the boots and the cape i mean kevin is
enormous he's like six eight with the
ears he's
like there's one point in the in the
film where batman ears are three more
yeah ten feet tall
and then with the boots it's like an
extra inch and a half he's probably like
six nine or something it's just he's so
big and when you look at him you're like
there's no way that you could crawl
through vents in the arkham game there's
just you don't even fit through my door
work like you know like
um there's a scene though in uh in the
arkham when he's walking
through arkham asylum in our film like
this uh gimbal tracking shot
yeah yeah yeah and we went there we we
went to location scouted it and
actually my dad was there and i have my
dad walked through and i filmed my
iphone we're getting all these ideas
i was like great well i've been walked
through here and then i and then i got
on the day i said i looked at the
doorway and i was like
i don't know if kevin's going to fit
through this doorway
i was like legitimately i think like and
if you watch it he literally like barely
misses it like on all sides and i was
like
like you're just so big but it's which
is great and that adds so much
presence because yes yeah for framing
yeah absolutely raymond it's like he's
just like even like shots because when
you look i have all these
batman statues and toys like batman is
so broad in the way that his trap so
look it just has this imposing look that
when you look at
the you know the actors on screen you're
like you just you look like a person
where kevin looks like
a fictional thing where you're like and
you don't have to like use camera angles
if anything sometimes i have to like
like i said get on like an apple box to
be like well like because they're like
it's just
we're looking up too much now kevin
looks like he's like you know nine feet
tall
and his understanding of the character
and like commitment to it and the way he
he's been doing it for so long because
he was that she was dc's official
batman 15 years ago like he was there
like when they did like the macy's day
parade when they did like the indy 500
and they have a batman there and
um oh i didn't realize that wow yeah a
lot of cop
and then a lot of comic artists would
use him as reference to draw him so a
lot of comics like back in the 90s and
2000s like that's
kevin you know so much that's what he
looks like yeah i was like
like this guy's too perfect you know
yeah okay that makes sense now all right
he's just been around for so long and
he's an actor as well you know he's been
in dodge ball he's always working on
different stuff he's been in
a bunch of tv she's just in a tv show
that premieres next year and
he's always working too he's not like
just a friend who also does the you know
who just
is trying to be an actor he's you know
working all the time um he's gonna be in
in my next film original film so he's
always
really into it but it's really cool
working with him
and like i said his voice his voice is
so much of everything he's got the jaw
he's got the eyes there's like just a
certain
seriousness that i like i posted a photo
of kevin just in the cow
and people like that's the best batman
ever there's really not a lot
i mean i always use his jaw in his eyes
but he has like a certain sharpness in
his eye you should really interview him
because
he's really uh he's actually not like
that at all in real life he's this very
boisterous
like super sweet nice like people meet
him and they're always like i thought
you were going to be a jerk and i was
like well he's not
actually batman he's wonderful to work
with
he he really wants to do another one
he's like so excited he's like let's do
another one and i was like we got other
projects to do but he he's a big reason
why i think our films look the way we do
and i'm like how can we not make a
batman project we have the best batman
ever he's incredible yeah were you okay
i gotta ask about
you playing joker i mean it's it's a
ballsy move i think
to be like i'm writing i'm directing
this i'm playing the [ __ ] joker you
know
like that's a ballsy ass move because i
i really think
most likely well everyone's like okay
have important even i just like even
i've seen the previous one you've done
and so i was like yeah this guy is
batman but
you were not joker before was this your
first time playing joker
i've been joking uh two or three other
times because i've only s i haven't seen
i
i only discovered bat in the sun um
around like
i want to say like a year ago so i've
seen like a lot of the videos sort of
sporadically
but with you still playing joker in this
and with the with the short film being
touted the way it is and for the central
scene to be you too
do you get nervous at all embodying this
role do you get nervous to bounce like
everyone has so much faith in like kevin
porter
does it make you nervous to like step in
here especially when you know we're
aware of how people react to whenever
they got a new joker whether it's like
jared leto or joaquin phoenix does
i think a lot more eyes will go on you
and i thought you pulled it off
wonderfully
by the way thank you thank you i
appreciate it um definitely i mean it's
a huge
i mean you know joker has been played by
some of the most iconic
iconic actors of all time and they've
all done great anything i do i want to
do it right i don't go in presumptuous
like i'm the best or whatever everyone
knows on set then i'm constantly asking
is that better should that be different
what do you think how does that
make you feel is it too much of too
little because joker exists in this
world
in a society there's so much ambiguity
to the character you can take them so
many ways you know like when heath
came out his joker was very different
than the comic books joaquin's joker's
very different and jared leto's
very different and a lot of people liked
him or hated them obviously
most people loved heath and you did a
great job and all these actors are
phenomenal i mean they've all oscar
winner actors so i i don't even put
myself in that
in that pool you know that's um you
should you should
i think you think it audience on the
inside you think it don't you
try to like you know you try to you want
to be as good as them
of course yeah but you know that's the
goal and hopefully i don't fall too
short
um the uh and i try to give it all like
i lost about 17 pounds for the roll so i
you know
god i got this just making wow that's
impressive that's really important okay
yeah i got down to 147 pretty thin for
someone who's six foot
um and then my face gets more gets more
withdrawn my eyes get more sunken in
um and i and we had the clothes taylor
fitted so it looked really skinny so i
looked really
you know gangly and stuff and then i
bleached my hair and my eyebrows they
weren't like sprayed green they were
actually i fully bleached them and then
dyed them
you know green um so like i had green
hair and green eyebrows for a long time
how long would you say you just had it
like that wherever wherever you want
well what's
so what's funny is that i i i don't
normally dye my hair for any reason my
hair is always just
dark and what it is um and then i was
like well i want to i want to really
commit i'm going to do this we're
putting a lot of money we raised
75 000 on the kickstarter we put 50
grand of our own into it so it came
around 127
was the budget like we're going all in
on this we want it to be great so i'm
gonna go all in i'm gonna lose weight
i'm gonna dye my hair so i probably had
and then when i was green though i was
like i don't wanna dye it back it just
takes like it's just like
i don't know like so i let it sit there
for a long time and i had my
my grandma she'd always be like when are
you dying it back because i don't like
this
uh well she like she was mine but she
was definitely green hair was
a bit much for a woman who's 92 but then
the green faded and i just had blonde
hair
and then i was her little three honda
yeah yeah like blonde hair after a day
at the pool
yeah like it was super blonde i looked
like like a 90s pop star
you know like i was in sync or hanson
but uh and then and then i eventually
just died back so i'm doing another role
i'm filming another movie in like six
weeks where i have to have my hair back
to my normal color
but getting into the joker mindset it's
pretty tricky because you're also
directing which is really hard too
exactly
to be back and forth luckily my my
father's there co-directing with me and
he can give me nuances because i'll act
and i'll think about like oh this scene
wasn't
i could have done that better and i
tried to bring my own
my own interpretation of the joker but
without strain too far like my voice
i took from like and i think you guys i
think you said it i just talked to my
dad
i watched a lot of reaction videos to
our work
and i talked most about yours i was like
i was like you guys got it the most
because you're the one that said you're
like i think
his inspiration was uh mark hamill jack
nicholson and smeagle
yes yeah
he's sick and he's you try to do a
little bit of mark in your voice
but not you don't want to fully
impersonate the way that like i did it
which is
uh you're like hey there batsy it's
wonderful to see you
whereas like mark you should just start
a cameo account where you could
people joke
who have done the character not not on
any professional level but you know like
it seems like a hard character to just
like flip right into it
yeah that's that was good that was
impressive yeah thank you thank you and
and marx is more you know mark cuz he
goes up more it's like hey there
betsy how are we today he's like he's
more up and down i can't do it
obviously as well as marcus king but
it's like i try to make that more
realistic
but take a little bit of jack little
caesar romero you try to find your own
try to be the comic books
and then give it your all like that
scene where i'm being choked
like that i was really joking it looked
like you were really being choked yeah
because we did it i was saying i was
like i can't you can't really fake being
choked then my dad came up and he's like
i think we're going to really choke
you and i was like that's fine i would
never ask any other actor to do that but
i'm also i used to do a lot of stunts i
did all the motion capture for
spider-man and the andrew garfield games
and
so like i know like how to be safe like
i was like if i have my hand in the
chain
but there's a clip and i'm gonna put it
online where kevin has the chain and
like beforehand he's clicking it like
where you can hear the chain links
because it's getting tighter
and i go and you'll see me go okay okay
i go don't don't go any further i go
because
the next the next chain link is death so
just like
jesus dedication jesus and i get through
halfway through that take and i
and and like i i also just kind of like
just start trailing off saying the wrong
thing
and then i come back to earth and then i
go okay i gotta do it again and i told
my dad i go i just there was enough
blood in my head i kind of just like
lost what i was saying you know and i'll
put that online so
you know there's that great yeah i don't
know if you guys watch friends but when
joey's on stage that director's
favorite show of all time gotta commit
to the moment
you got it um and then i throw my voice
out like even my voice right now like
there's
i put a clip on facebook just the other
day of me just screaming
and the jokers laugh as loud as i could
you know for a long time
and uh and then my voice gets more rough
so when i do the joker voice it feels
more
natural because you're having to do the
voice
you're having to act these weird
emotions because joker also and this is
kind of weird thing because joker is
never
weak like he's never like vulnerable but
he's kind of vulnerable here but he
always is on
and he's always on stage a lot of people
the one because i go through all the
comments i usually look at like bad
things because i was like how can we be
better that's really what i care about
and i get some people were like it's
like you were performing on stage you
know you were very expressive you're
overly expressive and i was like but
that was
i was like but joker is always that way
he's always on stage it's always
grandioso it's he's preparing this
monologue and i think that's just
because a lot of the younger kids are
used to
keith ledger now or the more modern day
joker they're not used to like the
animated joker who's very expressive
very
uh almost hammy and cheesy like i was
only like aaron your joker
was kind of hammy and i was like that's
the joker we were going for if you don't
like that joker then that's
that's fine you know you don't like it
but i was like but that joker is this
sort of
overly you know expressive excitable
never gets anything under his skin and
that's kind of the thing
on the film is that joker at the end you
know he's like you do care about
me it's like joker still wins at the end
of the film he doesn't lose he killed
the cops he got batman to come
there he got this whole one night stand
basically with him it's almost kind of
like this flirty relationship that they
have together and then batman leaves and
i was like joker
didn't lose in the film he won in the
film you know just kind of getting into
that mindset and then i have this very
crazy face
that i can you know
you know you have a crazy face here we
got a gift
that's really working they're like well
no i'll give you like i love your
prosthetics and i was like that was
that was my face and i got people like
well your face is so scary man it's
awesome and i was like you say that like
it's a compliment
i even got a few comments there like is
his face cgi because the way i can like
just shift in my
i have a very valid face yeah yeah but
you can make your eyes pop and your
eyebrows
can your eyebrows can go in yeah it's
really nice it is really unsettling
i'm remembering this right now you had
um you had a book on
uh in joker's uh room that is actually
one of my favorite
personal books which is conversations
with god
what was the purpose of putting that
book in there specifically well
there's there's like um like six books
in there and they were all chosen
specifically you know we had one one
flew over the cuckoo's nest
um which is where jack nicholson was in
that film and you know we had dr
seuss uh we had john lennon you know so
a lot of prolific very
culturally influenced people my dad
chose most of those books actually those
are all books from his actual personal
collection that he
had read and like he's a big superhero
fan understands the characters really
well so these are kind of the books
that he he like these would be good
books to have and um
and then i was like yeah so great let's
just you know let's let's just let's do
more whatever you want
i'm familiar with them i've read about
half of them but i was like these are
all good choices like you you came to me
all good you know that was really his
doing of why he thought those would be
good but
a lot of the books have been getting
people commenting on them but that's why
you know they're in there every
second every frame of the film is
something that we put in there like
arkham inmates have numbers on them
like joker's oh 40 ivy is oh six six
those are all the years that the
characters were created in the comic
books that's what they're not
cool okay cool awesome and then like the
woman like
at the where bullock is on the rooftop
and he's radioing to like one of the
police officers below and this woman's
like well if you're needed down for a
briefing
the woman's voice she is the
granddaughter to bill finger who
co-created batman
yeah yeah oh how well neat how neat so
there's all kinds of little
interesting easter eggs that we put in
the film that fans may
have not copied you know like i beat you
at the time i was gonna say i need an
easter egg
and a theories video
a lot there's a ton in there you know
that we try to put you know and they
were just like you know
you got the blimp switches from the
animated series you know ivy and the
animate series had like her one
rose pot which was like that was from
there's a lot of things that harken back
to the animated series uh and like we
say like
um it should oh it should have taken oh
at o'neill's toy land well that's danny
o'neil
or i say jerry's abandoned circus jerry
robinson created the joker
so we just showed up for like a lot of
little things now that the fans are like
you know oh wow so much of that flew
over our heads
not truthfully not true fans i should
take away my clothes
i i know that you have i know you're so
busy
and your voice is strained i honestly
feel like i could dissect a [ __ ] ton of
questions with you for like we could do
a four-hour
interview yeah i like i don't know i
don't want to keep you here too much
longer because i'm like man i can ask
about every moment in this or trying to
like summarize everything
okay one thing that really surprised me
was when i saw michael madsen
like michael because the second michael
madison was there was like oh he's a
perfect bully yeah like right away that
was like one of the best casting ever
and then you know it took us a while to
figure out that hugo strange was chris
daughtry
and doug jones was there as riddler so
you have all these celebrity cameos in
here
right are these guys like all your
friends or did you like ask them to just
be
here like how did how did all these like
big appearances just come to be
so it's all um a little little mix of
both i mean like
uh i've met doug jones a couple times
kevin is good friends with doug jones so
when i reached out and kevin reached out
doug was
more than happy doug's a big superhero
fan and the nicest guy you could ever
meet i've heard of doug jones for a long
time then when i got to meet with him a
couple times and he is
as sweet as he like people talk about
that he's overly sweet that he can't be
that nice and he is that nice
and that talented um all i've ever heard
about doug jones
like every single person yeah he's like
and when you meet him you're like you're
you
you are that nice like he's just like
he's like like like a wonderful cartoon
come to life like it's just
great but he always plays these creepy
people which is always i think so funny
you're the nicest person but the
scariest person on on camera and then uh
chris autry i've known for a while
uh he's a huge batman fan and he's a fan
of my work and i'm a fan of his work you
know i remember watching him on american
idol
so cool and he's he should have won that
year and uh
yeah he was a big you know he was a he's
a big batman fan i reached out to him
and he's like oh this sounds awesome you
know let's do it um but he's in
nashville
and he's like i can't come out here you
know i'm busy recording an album and
and um obviously there's covid's you got
to be protective but i was like that's
fine i go we only need you on a screen
so film yourself behind a green screen
in nashville and send me the footage and
i'll put it in there so that was all
footage that that he shot himself that
that i directed him through like a
little
zoom what about like the costumes and
stuff that he was doing
i sent all it to him i said all time
like i was guys and sent him and then he
grew out his beard
and shaved the mustache oh he did that
was really
hell yeah that's great he admitted and
then on his new album and then he had to
shoot his album
right after that so in the new album he
looks like hugo strange because
that is so awesome you can take direct
credit for that
it's cool he looks great i mean chris
says i can't say enough great things
about him he's super he's a huge batman
fan he like whenever i would
skype with him he's got all his
superhero batman stuff behind him and
stuff and
that's great how'd you get michael
madsen involved so michael
is a friend of a friend and um i
just basically he sent my stuff over to
michael he read the script he saw my
work he loved it
and then he was like i'd love to you
know to be a part of this
and uh we met talked about the project
for a little bit and then he's like yeah
let's do it and then he showed up and
it was a wonderful day on set michael
was he's just obviously super super
talented he's a great
actor he's as good as like when you show
up he just boom just turns it on
also my job as a director goes way down
because he's like i got it and you do
you watch
the take and you're like he's got it
like
and it also his his own personality is
very much like bullock like it's like
like when you watch like like predator
with arnold and you meet arnold you're
like well you know that's arnold like
you know
badass you know accent michael was great
and and he had great
chemistry with kevin and had so many
wonderful things to say about kevin and
um what's funny is that he watched some
previous footage that we had shot
already
because michael madsen was a few days
into the shoot and i sent it to michael
and when i was meeting with michael at
the hotel going everything he was like
uh
he's like is a is is batman is his is he
an [ __ ] on set and i was like no he's
he's a nice guy he's like okay he just
looks
he just looks intense i was like well
he's batman and then when he met him
because he was like you know his
michael's really nice
and uh and then and kevin's really nice
so it was so mike was really shocked he
was like oh you're like a really nice
like
like guy but like in the suit you know
it kevin's all scary but um
you know but michael killed it we did
long takes when i shoot i like to do the
whole scene all the way through just let
the actors
feel that energy so there are there are
a ton of takes that we i shoot a lot of
coverage too so like
a lot of the takes is just we have the
whole scene just right on michael uncut
just you just get to feel it you know
i'm saying it's cool like i kind of
almost want to release some of those or
some of my takes as joker because i
would do all nine minutes of just
just that's what it is to feel it you
can feel like just the flow of the actor
it just lets the actor perform better
than constant like one line one line of
course that makes a lot of sense but
michael was great though like he was
also like just
true professional showed up nailed all
the lines no drama
and he also between takes and lunch he
told us great stories about him and
quentin
and him on all these things and working
on you know all the huge movies that
he's worked on kill bill and sin city
and reservoir dogs
hateful eight and it was just cool he
was you know everyone you know a lot of
the cast is just
just like sitting there like you know
wanting to hear more that stories
because you know
it's pretty cool and he had a lot of
nice things you know to say about me and
that was
very nice so like he was super cool i
love that idea of like
these two tough guys they're secretly
really nice
is he gonna be nice to me coming in with
my garden
that's my favorite part of that story
watching the film i love that you know
in casting michael manson as bullock you
kind of
played with his persona because bullet
can be a dubious character and obviously
michael madsen
like when he shows up in scary movie
four you're like ah the punch line is
right there because
you know you can't trust this guy and so
i love that by the end of it he's not
really revealed to be you know a
completely dirty cop or something like
that so it had this
quality for me where i was sitting there
going i don't know if i should trust
bullock but i feel like i can for now
and so like
it made yeah it made it feel more than
just you know like stunt casting or like
oh cool we got this neat opportunity it
made it feel actually like a really
inspiring choice yeah we originally um
because the way we wrote it because
we've had this idea bounce around for a
really long time and we
originally wrote it where that was going
to be commissioner going on the rooftop
and we have uh
casper van dien as you know as
commissioner gordon but there's not as
much
tension there it's just more agreeable
and we thought it'd be so much better
conflict which is what you want on
screen
we have bullets where bullock is like
you know he kind of bends the law but
doesn't break it the way batman does and
he resents that
he resents that the police force needs
batman and he probably almost sees
himself as
the batman of the police force and he
doesn't trust batman but then you know
they're both good people
and they both want what's best for
gotham but they have different
ideologies which is why in that scene
they're really like they don't like each
other and bullock just straight up
insult to me because you're no different
than the joker because you're a madness
dweller too
and batman's like well let's let's pull
on that thread and see where it goes
whereas at the end of it you kind of see
that bullet comes around and says like
you actually aren't a bad guy you were
trying to help us the whole time
and batman is showing his true self
being like yeah i wasn't pushing you
around i was
i had a mission that was going to get to
you but then batman leaves at the end
and then bullock's just like i was
trying to compliment you and you just
left in the middle of me like saying how
great of a guy you are you're like an
[ __ ] but then in the final ending
monologue batman says bullock was right
so it's like they both concede
to like both of them being right but
they're like but we still don't like
each other but you can tell by the end
of the film that there's a mutual
respect for each other yeah
i mean like bullock was the the first
time i really felt like i saw more of a
nuance to bullock was actually in the tv
show gotham
okay that portrayal there was like he
starts off as like really one
dimensional [ __ ]
cop corrupt cop but then you see there
is a lot of humanity to this guy and
there's good in him
as i usually feel like bullock is he
usually seems like yeah you're the cop i
don't
want to hang out with so you're right
100 like i loved
seeing just bullock and batman having to
work together two people who don't want
to work together
who have to i thought that was a really
inspired choice how many giraffes
would you do you estimate you went
through before
you settled on this one is there a
rewriting in the middle of it uh no once
we had it done because we shot the whole
thing over seven days so we shot it was
a seven-day shoot
no frills oh my god do you think
do you think any more days or less days
i thought every more
we shot we shot uh michael matson scenes
in one day
um and those were all green screen and
that whole both scenes were completely
green screen none of them were on a real
they're on a sound stage arkham was one
day um mia's joker was two and a half
days
and then the hatter scene was uh was one
day so that's
six days right i can't even count um
and i even use my fingers um but uh
my dad figured it out we went over the
story a lot i think it's his idea to
even use bullock
um when it came up and and so we were
like yeah that'd be great and then you
know a lot of times we did is like me
and my dad and kevin got together and
just like
improv we had the motivations we had no
dialogue we want to feel like how would
it come out what would the characters
say oh
cool you know you want to let the
creativity you know breathe you don't
want to like force and micromanage
people's artistic ability like i want
you to i hired you to be you
and bring you so do that you know and of
course you want to forfeit people to fit
certain lines because you got to hit
certain lines just to get the story
moving forward but you know michael
improv a lot of lines and i just let him
do what he did
and he was great and then kevin you know
then bounced off that and kind of improv
knowing what the motivation the scene is
and what we have to establish but then
kind of you know
changing up a bit but uh me and my dad
went over that script a lot to get it to
where
it needed to be and hit all those
moments because i love those little
subtleties in like the depths like you
can watch the movie you're like there's
just a lot of talking in this movie and
then batman kind of like tricks joker
and i was like but there's like so much
more
into bullock into batman and the joker
that you're just reading the like
there's a lot in this movie like and
that's what i like i like psychological
stuff
you know that's what i yeah i was gonna
say i loved so much that it unfolded and
by the time it gets to the end like i
feel like in a certain degree up until
the point where the batman twist of what
his real
plan and what his real actions were is
revealed you know when that comes around
it jumped into an another caliber for me
where i was like oh wow you know we are
kind of exploring the whole sides of
batman
in a way that a lot of uh visual media
doesn't necessarily and then thinking
across
the rest of this i mean we were
commenting on and you brought it up
earlier you know how
you know we're picking out different
reference points and different
iterations of characters and so
when you are writing this and even when
you're you know on set or whatever
i got to imagine that you can't think
too hard about those
influences so are you pulling with
direct intent or is it more like you
have all this in your brain and then
from there we're just going to kind of
dream up something based on these
characters and
and see where like this seems like
something that could have gone through a
lot of different
shapes and a lot of different story
structures before winding up what it was
if that makes sense
yeah it it kind of does i mean i'm such
a huge batman fan that it's like really
easy like a lot of
you know when people take on jobs they
have to do research and figure things
out like i don't need to do any research
i've read
almost everything on batman and so forth
you know even like actually city of
scars which originally called dying is
easy and then we changed it to city of
scars because that story changed so much
that it kind of lost what we wanted and
then
diana's easy was actually originally
with mr freeze
not joker it took place in arkham and
freeze uh nora had died and freeze got
word of that
and then freeze was basically like i
don't want to live anymore but i'm on
all these
these machines are keeping me alive so
he calls batman and he's like i want you
to kill me because i have no reason to
live please take me off these because i
can't do it and it's about like just
[ __ ] awesome that sounds great yeah
this mortality let me switch it to joker
because then then you have like
the trick at the end where batman's
playing him because i always like that
it's batman's brain
that gets him in the end you know a lot
of the superhero movies it's just
batman uses his action and his fists to
overcome and wins the day but i like
where batman's like actually
i'm smarter and like at the end of this
it's like you know joker wants this
and joker's pushing batman and the
batman puts the chain around him but he
still won't do it so the joker's like oh
i have a card on my sleeve i actually
killed these police you know and he
thinks that's gonna send it over the
edge
and then batman's like well actually i
was doing this and then joker's like
well
i knew you really cared about me so it's
them constantly playing this chess which
is why we showed like a chessboard the
black and white chessboard in there to
show like that's
how those two always are you know back
and forth knowing the characters and
what you want to show like the
psychology to me going into it
and a lot of fans my email box is full
of people just like sequel do a sequel
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do and i was like i don't know if i were
to
do anything it would still be you know
very psychological in-depth even though
our beat down series is nothing but
action which is funny because i get
known for being action i was like i
really like
psychology that to me is what's real
that's more interesting like and
originally we wrote this
um we didn't have that fight scene at
the beginning we added that like right
near the end because
we probably need action in this because
that's probably you know and it looks
cool and we got a lot of great
moments in that and that scene was a lot
darker originally too which we had a
couple of which we had a pullback we had
it to where originally matt hatter had
no pants on the scene he just had tidy
whities
and then and then batman comes out we
filmed this when he comes out that shot
we're
looking at but him and he's like just a
scary like silhouette of batman with his
ears and he's walking over hatter he
says seven counts of sex
trafficking five counts of rape two with
a minor like he just comes out right out
and says it
and then he steps on his crotch and
blood goes everywhere and we're like we
have to cut all of this like we have to
get super sin city
and i yeah want to like that could
offend people which i don't want to do
it could it's not my property and i
might be taking it too far without their
consent i don't want to do that
and kids are going to watch this too
because batman is all ages so i was like
let's push that pg-13 rating but i don't
want to go full and i think that
sometimes pandering
you know when you go like too graphic
just for the sake of it because that
over that becomes bigger than the
psychology and then like i want the
psychology to be
always in the fourth yeah don't have
anything you interpret that yeah i'm
thinking tonally pacing wise too i
like if you start that big
one and then it's like oh now let's
tamper it down and get real
psychological i don't think it would
have flowed as well i think we would
have been like all right let's look it's
a gorgeous cross the line right yeah
let's keep it all good and we didn't
want to do that especially for how like
um
kind of like because the world is it has
its fantasy elements to it like it's not
like super super serious because i mean
you have a giant
lizard killer croc you know you have
it's all green
it's still fantasy you know like we
can't go like full the movie seven or
anything like that even though batman
would be great in that world but like if
you have an all green ivy
you know you have killer croc you have
mr freeze there is some elements of
fantasy and let's live in that world you
know so that's kind of where we kept it
but
do you want to do i remember the hashtag
being about hbo max
right we'll probably let you go after
that here you're talking for like an
hour here
and i really appreciate i appreciate you
taking all this time with us because
literally i'm like
keep going forever but do you want to
okay let me rephrase this you're telling
me you did this for
like a little over six figures and it
looked pretty phenomenal
like thank you and one of my first
impressions was
can you imagine they just got a little
bit more money
yeah yeah inch into that seventh figure
because a lot of the time i
you know you think of like oh you can't
really do a batman like a full-on
batman show like at a reasonable budget
and then i feel like
you've proven it even even from where
you went from
city of scars to dying is easy because
of like you watch city of scars and
it's like yes there are those elements
just a few years ago it was phenom it
was definitely still
great and that's 10 years ago how how
long 10 years
yeah was 10 years old oh my god
what does it feel like okay let me just
a side question what does it feel like
to go
and watch that now when you see what you
can pull off today
uh it's i've haven't rewatched it since
we released dine as easy
i'm very proud of you refuse to really
yeah no no no i i i love city of scars
kevin's great in that and the themes are
great because once again it deals with
there's
tons of you know a ton of psychology and
we use all the same music themes that my
dad created
uh that are in that film that are in
this film like he has his own batman and
joker music theme and you know it's just
it's ten years ago and
we see how we've improved his filmmakers
and you know we have an amazing effects
team
his name is nikolai zamka boy he's he is
so much a reason of all the visuals you
see
on there like we couldn't do that
without him he's now part of the team
and i think city of scars is really good
though
i would love to expand on that and this
it kind of this film takes place kind of
in that same universe same vibe i mean
obviously semi reboot right
yeah it's kind of like a reboot almost
you know we did a film seven years
before that or six years before that
called patient j which was a
psychological study of the joker
so really this is kind of like a
rebooting it's kind of like a hybrid of
them yeah
yeah yeah hybrid yeah so we want to just
put it all out there
but as you were saying for for hbo max
though yeah yeah is that something you'd
want to do
yeah yeah i um i've worked with like
lionsgate and sabon
hasbro partnerships with with dc and
stuff but nothing on like
that level that's you know i would love
to direct a feature for them like on hbo
max i'd love to do like a creeper movie
like a really like a horror movie nice
um you know like kind of a low budget
like couple you know five million and
fans started that petition online which
i don't know what that does but you know
like
it got it's up to like eleven thousand
uh
they started the the petition on like
the fourth day it was out which and by
that point we already received like
three million views
so i was like i was i want to yell at
the fan and be like you should have
started this on day one
you bastard yeah so many more signatures
right now
and then the hashtag uh uh my name aaron
johnny for ho max got picked up
and that started you know popping up all
over the place and i don't know what
stuff does you know i mean it could do
stuff i mean the fans you know i mean
obviously they got the snider cut going
so obviously that's
you know it's possible the fans can get
it going if this resonates with them
enough but
uh i would love to work with warner
brothers you know i mean you hear horror
stories obviously
about what happened tonight or what
happened to david ater no idea what
you're talking about yeah
i just want to be you know have a fan in
there who is a filmmaker who really
understands the characters who can bring
because i see i love watching the
reaction videos because everyone is a
huge fan like myself and it's great
it's like watching people's like
watching myself because i can't really
watch the film
as if it's new but i'm a huge fan and
like when i see them like oh i love this
part i love this part i was like oh good
like there's so much
love in the film that i'm like even
though it's not the big
you know official silver screen i've had
a lot of people say this is
my favorite batman this resonated and
you can't whether something is official
or not
how it affects you emotionally or
whatever it that
that their emotions are not affected by
that and i've seen a lot of people being
like this is the batman this is
my batman and i was like that's a really
cool thing for me my dad and kevin
that's what we tried to do
to be like because i don't think we've
seen it now if also it was on on screen
then i'm like well then we're
like you know i have no desire to make a
ninja turtles movie because they got it
right in 1990. you know they've not
[Laughter]
you know why why have we not gotten a
definitive batman yet
you know we've gotten close we've got a
lot of great batman's trying to say that
keaton and christian bale and affleck
weren't all great
they're just not like i feel like that
that's the batman that i
you know i've known as my childhood in
red so i want to put that on there and
if
people like it they like it they don't
it's free you know if you don't like it
and i'm like it's free don't watch it i
don't know what to tell you like that's
the weird part about youtube right
people have a lot of strong opinions
about free entertainment
but uh yeah i think i think he did a
beautiful job i think
i mean like the first great batman fan
film i ever saw was batman vs predator
that was like the first great one i ever
saw
but this to me i i genuinely i mean it i
do think it actually tops it like this
captured everything i love about batman
from
not just the look the aesthetic and like
feeling the characters come to life but
the psychological undertones to it all
and i feel like is this
la where you shot some of the stuff on
location you were from l.a so i was like
looks like la and um i'm always talking
about how i feel like nothing no
superhero stuff takes place in l.a
and i'm like i've got them to capture
that la's not a bad spot everyone's like
chicago new york so it's cool to like
get some la references in here
but i loved it i thought it was uh i
thought it was great and i can't wait to
see more and i hope
i don't know maybe maybe that matt
reeves show you can direct an episode
for or something like that down the road
or something like that that'd be cool
we'll get get the fans going and you
know we have our next project is a
legend of the white dragon
uh which stars jason david frank who's
the great
yeah we have an original project with
him it's kind of like how
the boys is like a homage to the justice
league but like darker and more brutal
imagine the white dragon um you could
see homages to power rangers but it's
its own original thing and it's
definitely a lot more brutal it's darker
a lot more
mature adult themes we pitched the whole
series to sabon and it was
i mean at the end of the day power
interest is a kid show and they're like
we can't you know we can't move above
13 year olds and i was like we want to
do like a real like a real series and
then like we just can't
do that so then i mean me and jason's
like all right we'll create our own
character and we'll kind of
you know so you feel like you know the
homage and we took it to kickstarter we
raised over half a million dollars we've
had
an investor come in so it's correct we
have a feature film that
we start production on in uh in six
weeks so
and i'm just waiting for that scene
where someone comes out of their
underwear
and someone gets smashed in the
scene to be like garage told us about
that yeah we're going to keep an eye on
all your projects now to see where that
gets when you're going
to applaud it you did it it finally
happened
i know i took it it's too much it's true
i don't want nothing
anymore it'll happen one day aaron
seriously
thank you so much for all this time and
uh for being completely present with us
like it really means a lot uh that you
took out time to speak with us
and thank you for uh thank you for
watching our reaction to my i haven't
even thank you for that thank you
like it was a good way to get to watch
and react to it because you know that
you enjoyed that is
the real treat bully like we watch my
dad watch it because um you guys say
because when we showed joker
we showed the um like the riots on tv
you guys were like i bet that has
something to do with the joker and i was
like oh
they picked it up i was like they have
the foresight but
i'm talking like you guys really nailed
it because you also talk to like some
people they watch reviews
and they'll just like just
and i'll be like like like react to it
you know like
i was like you just said it you said it
yeah
you know and i mean i love all of them
but i'm like i want to hear because we
don't you know i don't get a
we don't we can have a premiere because
of uh kazukovic and i want to hear
people like
react to it so you guys talked about it
and you talked about it very
intelligently you know you talked about
where i drew from my performance you
talked about the music that my dad you
talk about the end credit song that my
dad you know wrote which was great
all the different costumes and you
question a lot of things and
you could definitely tell that you were
analyzing it whether whether good or bad
you know i just want to hear people's
thoughts
on it and it wasn't just like whoa hey
you know like you guys don't know but
it's like
i watch because there was like 100
reaction videos to this video and i try
to like
try to like watch all them to like learn
and and you guys were one of my
favorites you guys were real smart and
picked up on a lot of stuff so it was it
was cool it was really great it was a
fun time
and i'm sure that my dad will end up
watching this video now
we'll post this i'll share this and all
the stuff doing these interviews is
really cool
you guys are super awesome i got i have
to do this at you with kevin smith uh in
like
in like two days or three days i think
we're a great warm-up for kevin smith
that's so prepared for the opening act
for him
thank god we're not an after again jesus
christ
you know why not we'll talk again right
after the kevin smith
i'm more than happy to come back honor
you guys are great like i said i love
this stuff and if you want to have kevin
on there or anything like that feel free
to reach out
please that'd be great and definitely
review all the stuff we've done and the
stuff we've done in the past
i'll be i'll be like waiting for like
when are they going to review this
i checked out quite a bit in the past
year and then when this came out i was
like okay we got to do a reaction and i
gotta thank nicole too
for yeah cory put it together she's been
really
i'm going out of town in a couple days
and um i'm engaged so we're looking at
weddings
congrats thank you so because of that uh
i've just been like so busy and nicole's
been so patient with me and i'm like no
but i really want to talk to aaron
i got to make this happen yeah that's
graham so glad also check out the one
beatdown where joker
fights negan that's a previous joker i
did like three years ago but negan is
played by kevin
porter and kevin put on like 30 pounds
of like fat
on that so because i feel like he looks
overweight because negan in the comics
is really heavy set he's not
skinny like like the way jeffrey morgan
is in the show so kevin was going off
the comic so people were like kevin
looks really fat and i was like well not
really fat he just looks
heavy you know and i was like i'm like
but that was on purpose kevin went from
being jacked to putting on like a lot of
weight so he looked full in the face and
you get to see like this kind of
southern negan batman
vs joker so watch that video and i'd
love to hear your thoughts
on how the dynamic is different but the
actors are the same
awesome all right thank you thank you
aaron best of luck i mean you're going
to kill it on your next projects can't
wait to see what else you do
good luck on the feature film and the
legend of the white drag is the legend
of the uh
legend of the white dragon jason davey
frank yeah perfect perfect thank you
this has been a blast seriously i'll let
you go now but thank you for everything
i really appreciate it thank you thank
you guys
stay safe and congrats again thanks guys
[Music]